Liz what conversations did you have with
Julian Julian Fellowes and when did you
have them well obviously because we were
we were embarking on something that was
really quite huge for us to do it was
clear we had well if we were going to do
a movie it had to stand on its own and
it had to be you know obviously we had
some key cast and most people don't
embark on making a movie with 20 key
characters plus guest cast but once we
start and Julian came up with this idea
we knew we had to get the narrative to
to really pull all the characters
together and all the storylines together
but of course you know when you've got
so many costs you have to have multiple
storylines and I think Julian is a
master of weaving those storylines was
the three-year gap just strictly trying
to get everybody together I know that
the very good folk at carnival who were
doing all the deals said trying to get
this cast together for this film made
brexit look like a walk in the park
there's how would you respond to anyone
who might say this is just another
episode I would honestly say look I
think there's a real argument that says
trying to turn a television series
that's been as successful as Downton was
into a movie that delivers is is the
hardest thing because you've got so much
baggage you've got to overcome of course
it's got its benefits because you have
an audience but we as I said we set out
we knew this had to stand on its own and
we have been incredibly gratified by the
feedback from people who said they'd
never seen this TV show but they loved
the film so I think it does stand up on
its own well there you have it what gave
you the biggest headache and what are
you the most proud of oh for sure we'd
had some practice at doing big ball
scenes but the the Kings trooped I mean
a it was the first time they had ever
taken part in any fiction you know they
are the ceremonial wing for the for the
Queen so we prayed nothing was going to
happen
a few days that we had them with us but
we had to move a hundred horses 80
people and six gun carriages from
village in southeast London to a small
village in the West Country in England
and the the location Department turned
to huge fields into an army encampment
complete with grooms and stables and
tacking rooms and barracks and mess
rooms I mean it was incredible and those
guys were so brilliant with those horses
I mean well they were fantastic and
there was one time they were doing the
they did a circuit for the street scenes
and one of the riders fell off and we
were thinking nah and then he just got
back up and got on again and then
carried on nothing had happened
it means extraordinary Anna do you want
to tell us a little bit about your
process and your prep I mean I guess
that's the thing from having been on the
series is that I I've worked with the
characters in my head and worked with
the cast for a number of years already
so I had this really lovely shorthand
you know I could spot an Edith original
across a shop within 10 seconds which
meant that I was kind of already up to
speed and when it came on to prepping
the film and was then able to spend more
time considering our new characters and
sort of researching the sort of new
characters that came in and the and the
real-life depictions of the king and
queen so yeah it was it was a kind of
familiarity that was amazing but it was
also quite challenging because I used to
have nine episodes hundreds of costumes
per character for the upstairs to to
tell to tell a story
[Laughter]
to tell a story through through clothing
over over nine episodes is almost easier
than doing it with one film where I had
to be much more considered about what
clothes I put on each character because
it was a much more edited considered
version of the whole series there was
something about the the visit the
Queen's dress she was telling us about
earlier oh yeah so Queen Mary was an
incredible character to costume design
for in such a challenge to design for
real-life characters and there's a huge
amount of reference out there to kind of
work from and I had an idea of how I
wanted her ballgown to be having
gathered just images of her in evening
wear and I worked with cause prop and
John bright who had some clothing that
belonged to Queen Mary for me to look at
and see how her clothing was put
together the construction the level of
embellishment and so we were sort of
going through that process and then he
said oh hang on a second I've I've got
some fabric that belonged to her that
was also left and and so he brought out
this roll of silk silver l'arme that
happened to perfectly marry up to this
piece of silver lace that I'd found that
I wanted to be the starting point for
the design and it was like this perfect
marriage of fabric so the the skirt that
that Geraldine James wears a scream
marry in the ball gown in the ball scene
and belonged to Queen Mary herself so
Lesley when you're in your scenes with
Daisy played by Sophie mushara you know
the the maternal side comes out a little
bit is that something that you and
Julian talked about to try to bring out
or is that something that sort of
developed now if we never discussed it
at all what I gathered only recently
that mrs. Patmore for instance was not
in his head originally going to be funny
but what Julian did with everybody was
he he sort of clocked what what people's
strengths were and it was my utter good
fortune that I got to play with Sophie
matira because the minute I met that
girl I just fell in love with her and I
loved working with her every minute of
it
she's a great actress and she's a
brilliant
person to be around and she's
hilariously funny and he he could see
that between us and so he started
writing a double act
but because I'm so we are very fond of
each other she calls me telly mummy and
in a way we've we've grown up with the
youngsters erm we we've we've seen them
grow up and we've come with them so he
that's why it went in that direction
without any doubt he just saw that
between us and he he made it work for
those characters and he did that with
everybody and I would say so Alan you're
the family fixer I think and you remind
me of another famous Tom in the movies
and that would be Robert Duvall's Tom
and the Godfather because you're sort of
the outsider in the family but you're
kind of on the outside but you're the
guy that gets it all done you yes how do
you feel about that I was delighted when
I got the the script I was very
surprised that Tom had so many elements
I mean he became dr. Phil to the royal
family which is like but I and all the
different elements and I was so happy to
see that love story begin to blossom
because it's something that I felt that
tongue really deserved at the end of
season tunics and he's for a long time
he's been on his own in that house so
and what I also love is the fact that
what you Lynne did so cleverly is he
create Tom's always been a victim of
circumstance he really didn't ask for
this life he fell in love with a girl
who sadly passed away due to contract
negotiations and and then so here Julian
took the braver choice to leave Tom
there and and but what I love is in Lucy
he's found someone who's a victim of
circumstance - and I love that idea on
how to say that scene at the very end
when they're dancing outside was never
scripted and it was completely the idea
of that lady there Liz Trubridge
romantic
who created it and our other producer
Gareth Neame said it'll never make the
movie and it proves him wrong and I most
certainly did and I love it because I
think it's lovely it's a lovely full
stop for his story as well do you still
take the underground around London and
are you not recognized I do
yeah I would say a lot of us still do I
do poetry totally um and you do get and
recognise the most enjoyable thing is
especially when the show used to be on
that someone will get on on a Monday
morning after it had been on and turned
to you and go hey have you been good
yeah great no I'm I don't know you do
you watch the TV and they go uh okay and
then they know where to get off at the
next stop because they feel a bit
awkward yeah well Elizabeth do you feel
like you have sort of infused Cora with
some uniquely American attributes well I
hope so I think that's inevitable given
the fact that I am American I'm playing
very hard to avoid I mean I tried from
the beginning to fight for my point of
view as an American to say but you know
I would do things differently I would
think about things differently I
wouldn't and I think and I did feel that
the script reflected that that often
Cora was able to be more flexible when
it comes to the traditional line on
issues and and I think that is the
benefit of the culture she comes from
and you you know Lord Grantham he's
still the lord of the manor and every
problem is still his problem is there
anything that you that wasn't on the
page that you felt like you brought to
Robert to help him sort of navigate all
of this I think I brought an immense
sense of being in retirement really but
well if you think about it you know
Mary's running the household even violet
says you know you're the next generation
I'm thinking what angle what about still
alive I'm still here I can but but but
that but that sense of handing on was
always there
you know particularly with Tom and Mary
as characters towards the end of the TV
show and that's that baton is still in
the process of being passed on but that
patriarchal figure I mean yes it's I
think it's delicious it's a bit like mr.
Bennet in in in Pride and Prejudice you
know that you know that there's this
whirlwind of women actually running
things and driving you know driving and
he just rather be in his study hiding
from it all but the key character let's
not forget is is the castle and without
getting to sort of philosophical and
sentimental it is a microcosm of the
world it will mr. Carson says at the end
in a hundred years time it will still be
here and the next generation will have
taken it on and our entire well I was
born my character was born to the duty
of preserving this place and passing it
on as best as possible as in the same
way we are on this planet to try and
pass it on as best as possible at the
moment we're not making a great job of
it let's face it and I think that again
is was something that the audience
relates to they identify with this sense
of place this this iconic building in
the middle of a landscape that has been
there for you know generations and will
be there for generations and we're all
passing through and each one of us knows
what it's like to be one of us I think
and I think that's again a key element
of the show what are you most proud of
in this film I would say each and every
member of not only the cast and crew
that have managed to take a very small
period drama in that I believe when we
started us as we all hoped it would do
well but the fact that we've taken that
through six seasons and now to the film
makes it it's such a sense of pride for
all of us because we are a family and we
are an ensemble in so many ways and for
me it's just it's the culmination of of
great friends great family great actors
great great technicians wonderful
artists so that's what I'm most proud of
I think I would say as an actor to be
allowed to be in something that has
truly touched people and made them
apparently this happy
is kind of what's why you joined in the
first place you know really I know
everybody gets the chance to have one of
these so I'm extremely proud to be to be
part of that sure I think I would I
would add to that that the responses
we've had not only to the TV show but
particularly now to the movie we've had
so many responses already saying it's
like being back with an old friend
and you know if you think back to when
the TV show for those who followed the
TV show it finished in 2015 the world
was a very very different place then
both in your country and ours and there
yes the show in itself by its very
nature has a sort of rose-tinted glow
about it it is about a different age but
it's also about a different age that
when we were watching it and we are in a
very peculiar state now certainly in our
country I won't speak for yours but we
are in a very peculiar place in our
country and our sense of national
identity is all over the place we don't
have a sense of national identity we
have families who are split down the
middle this the story that tone the
flavor of Downton you know whether it's
its social structure is right or wrong
it knew its structure it knew its
identity the people who would live and
work there know how they function how
they get through those that their life
in that house and I think there is a
great reassurance in that and I think
our timing as it was when when this TV
show came out is rather appropriate
people have said it's wonderful to
escape into something that is reassuring
for a couple of hours and that's what
our business is about thank you all
thank you thank this terrific group of
filmmakers